wonder if the events in your first year
as Governor the more intense hurricanes
doesn't that suggest that you should be
that we should be leaning into more
green energy not less to be clear what I
what I've called for is an all of the
above and in fact it's not reducing an
emphasis on Renewables wind and solar
it's correcting an error that was made
in the previous administration's energy
plan which was to exclude everything
else and this is why Common Sense has to
come back into this equation which is we
we can't evacuate one of our strengths
which is the fact that we innovate in
America we can in fact find a way that
natural gas can continue to be a huge
part of our overall power stack we can
innovate across nuclear and we can
Embrace Renewables like wind and solar
but we're going to have to adopt all of
them in order to get where we want to be
which is reliable affordable and a clean
power stack Jake who unfortunately you
know he's a Democrat he's just a
Democrat activist pretending to be a
journalist so he mentions all this and
shouldn't we be green